if you take for example the number of
recorded crimes per prisoner in this
country it's gone from six
per prisoner in um
in about
1910
or 1900
to 114
in
in 2000
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people a fascinating guest we have for
you today he's an author cultural critic
former prison physician and psychiatrist
known best by his pseudonym theodore
dalrymple welcome to trigonometry thank
you very much it's a pleasure i promise
to ruin your introduction i think i just
about got everything in
you have had an extraordinary life and
uh your work is very very interesting
before we get into it tell everybody
about your background who are you how
are you where you are how have you ended
up here talking to us yeah well i i've
ended up here talking to you because you
invited me
but uh i didn't break my way in or
anything like that but um uh well i
became a doctor i went to africa i had a
great desire to see the world so i spent
quite a lot of my life
touring the world
when i was young i had a slight
attraction to danger and
um
and then i
sort of settled down and
and was a psychiatrist and prison doctor
and one of the themes of your writings i
mean we'll we'll get into a lot of them
but one of the themes is a word that you
know if you were to utter it in the
confines of a normal tv studio i think
people would have a meltdown but
it is a word that is important which is
responsibility
is something that you've written a lot
about in the context of our culture what
are we missing around that subject do
you think well i think there's a lot of
double think going on in that people
think they themselves are responsible
but they take away responsibility from
other people so they see other people as
victors of forces if you like
but of course no one can think of
himself as a vector of forces until that
is he has to make excuses for himself
when of course he begins immediately to
talk about being a vector of forces when
you do something wrong the first thing
you
you think of as excuses for yourself
and then after a time you realize that
you're
you're telling yourself porkies and
but sometimes people don't get that far
uh they deceive themselves and often
they're given
uh shall we say advantages for for
deceiving themselves in that way so
they're both deceived and deceiving but
and yet there's a still small voice that
tells them that this is not true that's
my belief
and you say that they get given uh
incentives or get given rewards what
what do you mean by this well one of the
let me give you an an illustration once
i made a terrible mistake when calling a
social worker because i had a patient i
won't describe a bit but anyway i said
this is a particularly deserving case
well of course deserving is not a word
that you can use
because if there are deserving cases
there must be cases that are undeserving
or at least less deserving
and that means that you make a judgment
and making a judgment is a very bad
thing to do they're actually
the idea of not making a judgment is
itself a judgment so
it is a consequence of being a conscious
human being i think that you make a
judgment and the only way you don't make
a judgment is by being unconscious
so we all do make judgments
um
i don't know but we now pretend that we
don't is your point and what what
culturally what sort of impact does that
have in your opinion across our society
when we adopt this way of looking well i
think it allows people to think that
there's no other way than
they don't have to make any effort to
behave other than they are behaving and
in fact there are quite a lot of people
in the country and this is a bad
situation who are no better off if they
make an effort than if they don't make
an effort
they have nothing either to hope for or
nothing to fear
and that's an awful situation for a
human being because it takes meaning out
of life meaning out of effort
but unfortunately when you get to that
situation
uh often
you don't realize you're making
decisions you are making decisions but
they're often highly irresponsible ones
and foolish ones
and
you have been quite critical of the
welfare state
in some of your writings and
that is a dare i say anthony a very
controversial position what is your
criticism
well you see i don't think i wouldn't be
critical of the welfare state i don't
think the welfare state is
um shall we say a sufficient condition
for
what we're getting through there's a
necessary condition when it's allied
also to this kind of non-judgmentalism
where you you know
people
don't think one thing is best than
another that's a recipe for disaster
so in some countries where they have a
welfare state actually better than ours
uh which
though it does actually make judgments
more judgments than ours
it's all right if the culture is all
right it could be all right so it's not
the welfare state in itself it's the
welfare state in conjunction
with cultural developments and what is
the rise of our culture aren't we all
right aren't we doing okay
well i mean i suppose it depends which
end of the telescope you're looking down
or whether you see the glass half full
or half empty i would say that i mean my
view is that behavior
in this country is worse than any other
country that i know of comparable type
and
the behavior what are you talking about
well the rudeness the crudity the litter
free just take litter
britain is the most littered country in
western europe what does what lies
behind litter
people throwing away stuff
without due care right yes but what lies
behind that i would argue and this is me
being a miserable pessimist a certain
contempt
as in
i as in i don't care well let's i mean
yes i i i agree and uh partly the i
suppose they don't even see it or if
they see it they don't see that it means
anything
uh but i used to i used to go walk every
every afternoon or
three afternoons a week
from my hospital to the prison next door
which was a few hundred yards two i
i examined the litter on the way that
was always litter what i discovered was
an englishman's
street as his dining room
and you see what they eat
you see what they throw away
it's no wonder that there's an enormous
amount of obesity and so on and so forth
the other thing i learned is that the
fundamental cause of of car crime is
good weather
because when i went
in the sunshine
there was glass glittering everywhere
cars broken into when it was cold or
raining
there were no there was no glass so i
concluded from that according to some
kind of sociological thinking that the
real cause of crime car crime is uh good
weather but anyway
this kind of degeneration is absolutely
everywhere when you drive in this
country one thing i've noticed was very
to me interesting and significant
is that after road works have been
finished
nobody neither the council nor
presumably the
uh contractor takes away
the notices and and lets the frame just
rot
and their sandbags everywhere but you
don't see this in france you don't see
it in spain it's because nobody nobody
has any pride in what they're doing
the council doesn't do it the council
i don't talk about council
but they're not interested in that
that's beneath them of course because
they're trying to reform human
nature rather than pick up the litter
boom so you mentioned reforming human
nature yes now that is interesting to me
let's talk about that because we're
having this sort of slightly theoretical
conversation about a few things that i
may be indicative of this and that yes
let's get to the core of it yes when you
talk about councils trying to reform
human nature what do you mean well
they're they're trying to make people uh
better than they are um and they're more
interested
in
in
families so political correctness many
of them than in doing the things that
councils are supposed to do which is
look after the towns and cities uh
my council does all kinds of things
which uh which you shouldn't be doing uh
but it doesn't do those things which you
should be doing and this is this is
fairly typical of our
uh
of our government but
he seems to be worse in this
country than other countries sorry i
don't mean to interrupt i was just i'm
very keen on this point because i think
it strikes to the core of of some of the
things that you you believe
and people might be watching the same
well isn't that the job of councils to
create the right and sense of structure
to make people better than quote they
are as you put it no no they're there to
sweep the street
[Laughter]
and if they don't do that they can't do
that properly uh well i mean i don't
want them to change human nature of
course you can you can give people
incentive as we've talked about you can
give people incentives to make them
better or worse or at least
not measurable
not to change human nature but
but to
to make it that behaving badly has no
consequences or no apparent contact does
have consequences because
you know
you can't escape bad consequences but
not not immediate bad consequences for
ability to eat
or have a roof over your head or
anything like that
so um
we get all kinds of nonsense now about
people changing sex and so on and so
forth and you see what happened to the
the professor of
philosophy she was in that chair a week
ago oh right well she she was saying
things which i would have thought 20
years ago no one would have thought
worth saying because it was so
self-evident
um and now she's been persecuted for
them
it's it's true she has been persecuted
for them was there a particular moment
anthony where you started to see culture
and the world changing or do you think
it's been a gradual slow creep well you
could never point to a i mean you can't
say that like virginia woolf said human
nature changed on the 11th of november
1910 or something like that of course
didn't really mean that and you can't
point to anything like that if you start
thinking like that then you go back to
the
garden of eden
so
uh
obviously if you said is there a point
at
which uh i saw culture changing
no but it gradually dawned on me and i
suppose my experience
of of working
as a doctor in a slum and
in a prison did
did open my eyes because most people
in my situation middle class situation
wouldn't even know that any of this
existed and in fact once i was um asked
by a bbc correspondent actually a very
nice man
um a very distinguished man actually
he said well
do you make it all up what i was writing
[Laughter]
and uh
and i
that explains like the last 10 years in
one sentence doesn't it yeah
so i mean how he could have avoided
seeing it i don't know but people doing
i mean there's a book in front i mean
it's not only in britain there's a book
just out in recent fairly recently out
in france called the french archipelago
and it's written by a sexual
geographical sociologist or whatever you
would call him who says that now people
are living in
we've balkanized our own societies so
people outside that that group and these
groups are quite large i mean if you
take the bobo the bourgeois bohemians
there are now
hundreds of thousands or millions of
them so there's no reason why they
should meet anyone outside their circle
and likewise people
who live
in a
some terrible housing estate somewhere
probably never meet anybody who doesn't
live in a
except in you know when if they're
working in a supermarket or something
like that so we
we live in a world in which we don't
meet many people who are not like
ourselves and i was privileged to meet
people who were not like myself who were
living very different life from me and i
was interested and
i think one thing that helped me was
having um
traveled a lot around the world and one
time for example i i went across africa
by public transport
and
really all judgment is comparative
so having seen that
having seen for example how really poor
people i mean i'm not talking about
not having all the things they want and
they really had very little indeed and
might not
even have had enough to
couldn't be sure that they would have
enough to eat the next week or month
and i saw that these people were
actually
dignified
polite
and in some ways more civilized
than
people in this country well what do you
mean by that well they behaved in a more
seemly
way yeah
and um
[Music]
and i found that pretty amazing even
though they had less they had they had
far more dignity with the way that they
behaved than with people here yes and
what do you think and why do you think
that is do you think because we we
indulge people here do you think it's
because we're more spoiled as a society
is it something to do with well i mean
i suppose i would be spoiled
foreign let's be fair yes
yes so uh
but i think people don't really know
what that kind of hardship is
um
as they i mean it's not that long ago
that people didn't know that kind of
hardship in this country
but anyway
i think people take a lot more for
granted
and those people didn't take anything
for granted they couldn't take anything
for granted i mean i'm not isn't not
that i advocate going back to to living
in that kind of poverty or anything like
that
but that
meant that poverty is not is not a
simple uh phenomenon that impacts on
human personality there must be
something else i guess what you're
getting at is in the west we have the
notion that crime misbehavior whatever
other behaviors that we don't like and
don't want to encourage
people are often saying that it's a
product of poverty and your argument is
it's not
i mean it's uh
where you couldn't know that from from
from
statistics in britain i mean
when britain was a lot poorer it had a
lot less crime
i mean the the level of crime has
shot up immensely since uh since
edwardian times now people will say well
of course the statistics you can't judge
by the statistics because they're kept
differently and so on and there are
reasons both for thinking that there was
more crime than when recorded then and
but also there's a lot of reasons for
thinking there's much more crime than is
recorded now here
so i mean in general one can say pretty
certainly that
uh there's a huge amount of i mean it
goes up and down
of course from year to year but there's
an immense amount of crime by comparison
with what there was in in the
in
before the first world war and even
before the second world war i i mean
i've forgotten the exact figure but
there's sort of more robberies
uh
in one london borough in a month than in
the whole of great britain in in 1930 so
i mean it's
anyone who can remember
knows that this is so of course they've
been
again they've been condescended to by
criminologists who tell them that it's
the fear of crime rather than crime
itself but
that's simply not so and why has this
happened
ah that is a difficult question right
and i'm not sure i
can i can't say well i know this is the
here is the answer give us some pointers
um
well uh for one thing uh
uh
there's very little repression of crime
the the criminal justice system is
incredibly lacks
and people think that we're hard on
crime we're not at all hard on crime and
every every um
every government that has tried to do
something about it has been stopped by
by
forces that are beyond their control
um
but if you if you take for example the
number of recorded crimes per prisoner
in this country it's gone from six
per prisoner in
in about
1910
or 1900
to 114
in
in 2000
114 by comparison with six
jesus christ
so
i worked this out from the statistics
this is known to the police
okay
so in other words
um
you can come in as many crimes as you
want in other words pretty much
well i'd
i wouldn't go quite as far as that i
think it depends on you're right anthony
you're right if you commit murder you
probably go to prison my point is if you
can if you're allowed to commit 114
crimes that's that's not the state
attempting to keep you from doing that
it's not really no it's the state is
failing in one of its primary duties
and that is to keep
people more or less safe as they go
about their legal
now the point is that people like
you and me
don't suffer much from this
but i used in the morning i used to hear
the stories of people who have been the
victims of crime in the afternoon i
would go and see the people who
committed the crime and i you know
i actually got on i think i liked
the prisoners and
and they go and they told me of course
what they'd actually done by comparison
with what they've been charged with
having done
and it was a very different story
uh and because they knew i wasn't going
to tell anybody i'm not not specifically
i've told
i'm telling you in general terms but i
wouldn't say this particular prison did
this and that um
and all of them had done between five
and twenty times as much they have been
caught for doing and um
and the
figures bear this out
i mean the the the number of uh crimes
that are actually
actually solved in the sense they find
out who did it uh and charge them is
something like five or eight percent
and
and when they are charged nothing much
happens to them it's easier apparently
to find someone who has
been convicted 40 times in prison than
to find someone who has been convicted
only once
wow
so
and when you consider that someone who's
been convicted 40 times has probably
done
between 5 and 20 times as much as you've
been charged with
you realize
that uh
you know that things are not working out
very well
in a way
i would say there's this is grounds for
optimism
because when you consider how pathetic
our efforts are taken
repressing crimea
the fact is there isn't much crime i
mean we're not
i don't know about you but i'm not
tortured by crime or anything like that
i i assume when i go down the street i'm
safe and so on and so forth i mean it's
not true it depends where you live
but actually the question is not why
there is so much crime but why there is
so little
and that means that most people
fundamentally are law abiding what
there's a reason for pessimism is that
theoretically it should be
easy to reduce the crime rate very
considerably and yet we consistently
refuse to do it
and why do we consistently refuse to do
it
because
most people think that if you're
if you regard punishment as any part of
the criminal justice system you're a
torturer or a
sadist
and the truth
is and the truth is that i i i don't
think i'm not advocating bad treatment
of anybody but i think that the the the
extreme
when we have a lord chief justice who
says that first-time burglars shouldn't
be sent to prison he says that first
time burglars that already shows he has
no idea what he's dealing with because
the chances are they're not first-time
burglars that's the first thing so he
doesn't know what he's talking about the
first time convicts for a birthday first
time they're first-time convictions you
must always
remember that a conviction is not the
same as the number of offenses
and and this is a very simple thing the
other thing that people forget
is when they they think oh well he's
middle class and so on and so it's easy
for him to talk someone's had an easy
life and all that they don't know
whether i've had an easy life or not of
course but anyway they can say that
and they say that uh criminals
on the whole have had hard lives and
that's true but
many of them have had hard lives
and so on
but the fact is that the victims of
crime
are also poor and since the number of
victims is much larger than the number
of perpetrators
failing to incapacitate the
uh
the
perpetrators
is creating lots of victims who are and
for
poorer people who are not themselves
criminals because poverty is not
criminal
um
it makes their life much much harder
so in many ways what we're failing to do
is we're failing to protect the poorest
and most vulnerable people in society by
these policies or methods or whatever
you might want to call them exactly
but you see what it enables
people like me if i were of a different
opinion and i probably would have been a
different opinion if i hadn't sort of
worked amongst this for so long
um
is that it enables them to think good
well about themselves they're being
generous and so on
uh when they're not actually of course i
mean you could say well it's the means
by which the middle class avoid having
to pay more tax
for a proper criminal justice system
and when you look at the people who are
perpetrating the crimes is a is there a
type as it were
or is it just every different
um
could be a personality type not
necessarily comfortable i never really
never really thought that i mean
obviously you read of course that in
prisons there are
uh
that 70 percent of prisoners have some
kind of psychological problem or
psychiatric problem i believe that's a
whole load of hokum and that's an a that
is an excuse
for the failure to deal with the
relatively few raving lunatics in prison
which the nhs is incapable of dealing
with
because it's so incompetent
and uh we've closed down all the
psychiatric hospitals so you can't send
the lunatics anywhere and you're not
allowed in a way rightly you're not
allowed to treat them in prison against
their will so they just stay there and
rot
but you cover up that deficiency which
is a real and in my view
should be an easily soluble
problem because it's it's not a huge
problem
um you cover that up by saying well
there's 70 of them well what can you do
with 70 of 80 000 people i mean you
can't do anything
you know but the whole process of
diagnosis is so lacks
and that
that you can claim these things and
nobody will nobody will bat an eyelid
say well this can't be true
anthony i
so i was a teacher for many years and i
read a stat and correct me if i'm wrong
maybe is wrong i think i read it in the
times as a educational supplement so we
can blame them if it's wrong but
something like 50 percent of all
prisoners have a special educational
need whether it's dyslexic whether it's
you know things
i don't i don't believe that for a
minute
and uh
it is said
that prisoners are on average of lower
in iq than the general population that
may or may not be so
but i found that i never had to talk to
the prisoners in any different way from
how i'm speaking to you now that night
i mean there's more than one possible
interpretation
[Laughter]
but
but i when my interpretation was that
they were not deficient in intelligence
they could understand everything
perfectly well and i never had to alter
what i was saying i mean of course there
were a few who were very
noticeably uh of
low intelligence and there were some who
were mad
and there were a few
who were a bit like hannibal lecter but
they were very few
and generally speaking i found them to
be a perfectly adequate intelligence
that's perfect you know anthony i feel
listening to you a bit like a
four-year-old talking to his dad and
every question is why why why this why
that because you're opening up boxes
that we've not looked in
yeah on this show
so
you've worked in a prison
you've worked with people in that
situation just
what are the things that people don't
understand what are the things that the
myths that we keep being told what are
the things that we ought to understand
about the prison system prisoners
criminal justice all of that
well i think i mean people for example
people will often
give you a statistic saying that we have
more prisoners per head now you've
probably heard this than any other
country in europe which is only barely
true because spain
has almost as many
uh
but the statistic
the number of prisoners per head is a
ridiculous one
because of course you're not there isn't
an ideal statistic every country must
have a hundred prisoners per million
it's not a target
that irrespective of the number of
crimes i mean if there were no crimes
then even to have one prisoner would be
an outrage
so the fact that i've never heard
anybody say that that statistic is
ridiculous it means nothing
it's only by comparison with the number
of crimes that it makes any sense and
the fact is that this is the most
crime-ridden country in western europe
by far
wow so the fact that we have slightly
more people in prison per head of
population actually points to the fact
that not enough people
the last time i looked at eurostat and
admittedly it wasn't
it didn't have the latest statistics
but
the number
of
violent crimes per prisoner in spain
was a fifth or a sixth of what it is in
england in other words if you commit a
violent crime in spain you're five or
six times more likely to go to prison
than you are in england
and
only a criminologist would be surprised
to learn that the rate of criminal
violence in spain is much lower than in
britain
you have to have a certain level of
education to be surprised by that
i mean you or you probably are not all
that surprised no i don't know uh bro
thank you for that uh we're very badly
educated as you point out but um
again i come back to the to the why
question you made one point which is as
a culture we have become uncomfortable
with the idea of punishment
and i feel that i feel that in myself i
feel
that
even when i was growing up the idea that
people respond to incentives and
punishment is a disincentive yes or an
incentive depending on the circumstances
was universally understood and by the
way sometimes that principle was
misapplied
and the punishment was far too severe
for people uh the way children were
treated was just outright wrong in many
ways
right people uh you know physical
punishment all these sorts of things
i would argue or wrong
why has that changed
um
i don't know but let me just go back a
minute no one wants a society in which
the only reason that people behave
reasonably well is because as a
policeman around every corner if he
doesn't behave well then
they get nicked they get nicked so
you've got to you've you've got to try
and distinguish what prevents people
from becoming criminals in the first
place is what you do once they have
become criminal once they start behaving
criminally and these two questions they
overlap a bit but they're not exactly
the same
[Music]
and they are confounded so whenever
people will say well what's the root
cause of crime the root cause of crime
of course strictly speaking is the
decision to commit it
a very unfashionable view nowadays
in fact there can't be any crime without
decision takers if you don't take the
decision you're not criminally
responsible so in other in other words
although it sounds trivial it is
actually the case and i always treated
people as if they had made decisions
they might have been very bad decisions
there might be
stupid decisions they were forgivable
sometimes not always
although i don't like the word
forgivable i would say
either excusable or comprehensible
because i can't if i if someone does
something wrong to you i can't forgive
him only you can do that
i have no
locus standard in the situation but
anyway
so people
and it's perfectly true that uh
that it's it's difficult to be in favor
of punishment because
punishment has been terribly harsh in
the past and cruel
sadistic actually
and you know when when we when it was
carried out in public half
half as deterrence and half as
entertainment
that that was horrible and um you know
one doesn't want to on the other hand
one has to get be realistic
so that for example the reason you don't
park on a double yellow line
is not because you um
because i'm going to get a fine yeah
you're going to go that's why i don't
park there yes yeah and if i didn't get
a fine i would park there probably
guaranteed in my case definitely i mean
you knew two things the chances of
you getting the ticket in the first
place and then when you then having to
pay the fine if it was just the ticket
if they just told you as the police now
tell you uh if you just assault someone
or something don't do it again
well it doesn't matter i mean you've
been caught but it doesn't matter
whereas with the ticket it does matter
because you will be fined
um
so
um
uh
yes well
we started with i the question i was
asking you is why why we've become
uncomfortable about applying punishment
i think there's been a long process of
propaganda probably starting with the
i mean if you have to put a start of it
i'm not saying that you you know someone
will come and say well it was before
that but uh if you take the
fabians for example say someone like
bernard shaw would write about
uh would write about
criminology
and uh he would argue all the the things
that i now
oppose now he was living in a society in
which crime was actually a very minor
problem
but he didn't know that he couldn't have
known that because he didn't know that
it was going to explode later
so many
reformers i think
do not consider the possibility they
make things worse rather than better as
they can make they can make things
better but they can also make things
worse and i've just been to an
exhibition at the welcome gallery and
welcome collection institute yeah
um
and uh it's about happiness and they
were saying how political activism
um can make you happier
and and it can make things better well
that's
that is true it can make things better
but it can also make things worse
because they gave an illustration of how
you know marching in the streets and so
on and on it exactly fitted the nazis
you know now
so there's an example of how activism
can make things a lot worse
and this doesn't seem to be a
a uh a problem for for activists
i don't think many think well actually
things might get worse as well as better
and nobody and dr johnson said that all
judgment is comparative now what they
compare everything with is some kind of
utopian vision that they have in their
mind not with what actually exists and
what has existed
and what could possibly exist
so
um
they're not very good at making
judgments people are not very good at
making judgments and anthony why am i
always hearing this statistic about you
say that crimes exploded that violent
crime is going down that the
society isn't as violent as it used to
be
oh well that that might well be true i
mean it depends you see you cannot
it depends
where
what you look at
so how you look at it i mean my
financial advisor will always show you
that your
investments are doing very well it
depends
he carefully selects the states from
which the graph starts
yes i take your point so it might well
be
i mean
if our crime rate halved first of all
the incidentally uh there's abundant
evidence of manipulation of the
criminal statistics i'll give you an
example in a minute
um but
but it could go down by half and still
be incredibly much higher than it was
in 1910 now you can say well what's the
standard of comparison i'm not saying
that it's not a good thing if the crime
rate goes down of course
we would all welcome that but it's still
very high
um
so what was the example you were going
to give well i was getting off this
manipulation well it used to be there's
a lot of
you've probably heard about the
recidivism rate
of non-custodial versus custodial
sentences and that's always been
extremely crooked statistic
because of course while
it
it starts from the
uh
period of release
of the prisoner
and the
and the the date of sentencing of the
non-custodial sentence well of course
while the prisoners in prison he's not
committing crimes
unless he's committing them against
other criminal other
prisoners which can happen of course
but that doesn't happen that often
so that in itself is a crooked
comparison
secondly the people who are in prison
have all been through the uh
the non-custodial system because they
don't go into it it's very rare that
someone except for a crime like murder
goes into prison the first time he's
convicted so he's been through the whole
mill of rehabilitation and so on before
he ever gets to prison
but anyway they used to um
they used to use a two-year comparison
and suddenly
and they used to call it they used to
call it reconviction rate and then they
changed it to reoffending that rate
which is a lie in itself because the
reoffending rate is not the same as the
right as the commander
committing an offence and being
convicted for it's not the same thing
right
uh and won't it will never be the same
thing and it certainly won't be the same
thing with our police
um so so we're looking for the keys
where the light is as opposed to where
we dropped them essentially on that
particular yeah and and the fact is that
you have to
you have to look at the statistics with
the extreme
skepticism and it then they make it very
difficult
you know this so suddenly they change
from
a three-month uh two-year period to a
three-month period where how on earth
are you supposed to compare whether
things are getting better worse or
staying the same you can't it becomes
impossible and anthony the one thing
that i really wanted to talk to you
about what is the rehabilitation of
prisoners
is it effective or are we just creating
a system where someone goes into prison
you effectively lock them in for 11
hours of the day however long it is and
they come away learning nothing from the
experience or anything actually worse
no it's not true that they
get worse and actually again prisoners
rehabilitate themselves in a certain way
because if you look at the age at which
prisoners come into prison for a new
sentence
for crime
not sexual crimes but crimes such as
burglary or assault
they stopped spontaneously
by the by the well before they're 40.
really yeah so they're very very few i
mean there are some of course
but the idea that they go on and on for
the rest of their lives is not true
or at least they don't get caught
after the age of they've worked out how
to get past the system that's that's the
advantage with being a veteran
so that suggests that they are
self-rehabilitating
and that of course i mean would lead
some people to say well there's a
biological component
which is probably true the reduction in
maybe a reduction in testosterone
aggression but also i mean
the fact is it's a young man's game if
you want to run away it's better to be
young than old as i can tell you
from experience and not that i'm running
away from anything but i i couldn't run
away from anything very much so
um
but anyway so the idea of rehabilitation
is uh
and it's not as if it hasn't been tried
and it's been tried but it it doesn't
seem
uh to work
and uh except in the sense that people
eventually and that's a good thing of
course that they eventually
uh get over their life of crime
and
presumably they find jobs and things
like that and i'm all in favor of that
of course
and what do you think about the whole
having to disclose criminal records do
you think that actually stops people
from rehabilitating re-entering into
society or do you think it's a good
thing for job applications
i face i i face both ways there i mean
i'm in favor of of course allowing
people
uh
a second chance and even a third chance
or a 48th chance in some cases
but uh
um
and so i can understand why one
shouldn't
uh
on the other hand if i'm employing
someone uh in my to do my accounts i
would want to know that he was a
convicted embezzler
so
uh
i think it's a difficult and if you like
as an example of how there is no perfect
solution to to that particular problem
i mean
ideally what you would like is for
people
to know and to want to give people a
chance it's your decision that you you
say you take this person you're prepared
to take the chance that
he's
that he's reformed
um but
all changed
but um i
i i don't see a simple solution to that
a simple rule that a rule will
[Music]
if you make a rule it'll be hard on
on
somebody yes and and we're talking about
rehabilitation
and we're talking about reintegrating
people what do we do with people who
have
offenses sexual offenses
and
how do you reintegrate those types of
people into society because that is a
that is a question for the ages because
when someone goes in for a sex-based
defense
a lot of the time and you could argue
quite rightly their career is finished
their reputation is destroyed
is there ever a way to reintegrate those
people back into society or is well
again i mean i think it's the same
answer isn't it you want those people
you don't want people i mean you don't
want people automatically to have a life
sentence
um
on the other hand
you can understand why people
don't want someone like that living next
door to him
so
i'm not sure i've got i i think we
there's no simple answer to that but
also we have to
we have to
get the
the um
a sense of proportion in that this
really is not
a huge
vast problem like some other
things are a big a much bigger problem
uh
before i was going to ask you another
why question but let's stick with that
when you say it's not a huge problem you
mean statistically speaking comparative
obviously to the individual victims yeah
i just wanted
you can easily look very callous by
saying it's not a big problem because
then somebody comes along and says well
it happened to me yes
and i had a colleague who was caught yes
caught out like that
on a program he was put in a an audience
and he was a
psychiatrist and he was asked about
schizophrenia and murder
and he said well actually he gave the
statistics and so on and said this is
not a
huge problem and
and so on and so forth
and of course they put him next to a
woman whose husband had just been
murdered by a schizophrenic and that i'm
afraid is
uh that is good well that is the
technique of uh uh
television
well and i made the comment for those
people but i also want to ask you what
you mean
by that
which crime
is the big issue you think well there
there are several uh
and and many smaller crimes of course
are not individually very important
but are
cumulatively important
and have bad effects
so that for example shoplifting which is
not a terribly serious crime but if it's
bad enough it will drive people out of
business and take uh close down shops
and so on and you can see it in suburbs
of paris there are no shops and
some of the suburbs have passed nobody
will open a shop there
and it's not that well i mean there's
arsenal as well but um
so you can say that although each
individual crime is not terribly serious
uh cumulatively it is very serious
um
but
assault is very serious uh
yeah yeah i if you don't mind me going a
bit off uh off the track here
go for it to give you an example of what
our police are like or what some of our
police are like
in the hospital in which i work first of
all when i started we had porters then
we got security of
uh security men and finally got a police
station on this in the hospital
and um
and that
they of course did nothing and once on
one occasion
a policeman watched a nurse being
assaulted by a drunk
and did nothing didn't arrest the person
or anything like that
why not
well it's normal
well because there's so much paperwork
for lynn afterwards
and as one chief constable said to me
you wouldn't want our police to just be
filling in paperwork would you
so anyway
i mean you put it in print
so um
didn't mind doing that paperwork
no
so anyway uh
and i wrote to the chief constable
saying this has happened
and he wrote back and said no no it
doesn't happen it never happened
that didn't happen
so
anyway
i left it i i was pretty disgusted by
his answer but anyway
uh he said we always take all crime
seriously et cetera et cetera
he's like a politician
and of course the chief constables are
politicians they're not policemen
anymore but anyway
about three months later notices started
appearing all over the hospital saying
from now on
anybody assaulting a member of staff
on the hospital premises will be
will be uh charged
okay which was an admission that what he
said before was a lie
and secondly it was rather ambiguous
anyway because it rather suggested that
assaulting someone other than a member
of staff
or not on the hospital premises was all
right
and they often say the police often say
these things without actually
understanding what they're saying
hey francis do you like books i only
like comics that's why my favorite
publication is the guardian it's true no
one does satire and parody like they do
so did you have a brilliant satirical
book for me yes it's a book by one of
our fans scott paciano and it's called
identity crisis it has been described as
1984 with jokes so it is like the
guardian no no no it's intentionally
funny so in present day north west
london it tracks the personal journey of
cocksure city boy dave dalston through a
period in which the government has
decided to define everyone by their ego
profile by a document called the id card
it's a roller coaster ride through
cancellation redemption and spiritual
enlightenment the author has been a fan
of trigonometry from the very start and
he has drawn a lot of inspiration from
its conversations so if you're a fan of
trigonometry then you're gonna love this
book anton we are getting our ten
percent aren't we
check it out on amazon guys the link is
in the description below
so let me let me come back to the to the
why question you you said earlier that
politicians had been elected to address
this issue
and were unable to do so due to quote
forces outside of their control i think
is what you said
civil service mentality and
don't want to
to change
they're afraid also i mean they're i
think they're afraid of
i think they're afraid of the guardian
actually
and the commentary
um
and you see you don't get much
q
you don't get much kudos amongst
intellectuals by saying the kind of
things i'm saying no
i mean i wouldn't advise you to say it
at dinner
parts you're operating under the very
false assumption that i still get
invited to them which i do not uh you
know i i've given up attempting to be
liked by people that i despise a long
time ago but well i don't i don't
despise them i just think they're
mistaken yeah yeah yeah and i once had i
mean the only time i've ever persuaded
anybody actually was a man called
jonathan miller the theater producer
for whom i had a high regard who was a
very decent and obviously highly
intelligent man and he was a brilliant
theater producer
and
my
you know he was
had the standard view of crime and
it's all poverty and so on and so forth
and i was and i managed to persuade him
a bit otherwise and he just said well i
i don't have the argument against that
and therefore i must accept it
but that is very correct no when i say i
despise what i mean is there is there is
a group of people that if you have the
wrong opinion see
they will ostracize you they they
believe that you should be pushed out of
polite company society et cetera that is
behavior that is worthy of contempt
personally but people well i think
what has happened and i can't explain
exactly why i think that
the the idea of virtue
is now almost entirely
a matter of opinion i mean not in the
sense that you if you have the correct
opinions you're virtuous
if you don't have the correct
opinions you're a monster or you're a
bad person
now i don't take that i don't take that
view because i think
many people with wrong opinions that i
consider wrong are very virtuous good
people quite
um
so actually opinion is not virtue
um so what is virtue
oh well that's difficult but i think it
must involve to a degree behavior
[Laughter]
oh how old-fashioned yeah
what a world what a world that we live
in and
do do you think we need to reform the
prison service do you think it needs
radical reformation
um
i must say that i think things got
better in my in my time i mean don't
forget i've been retired from it for 15
or 16 years so i'm talking entirely from
memory and i think having conditions
improved enormously i'm glad to say
while i was
in
prison
i would like to i mean the thing
i've said that rehabilitation i don't
really believe in rehabilitation but
what i would like to see
is more effort at
a cultural activity in prison
and i am in favor of education just
because i'm in favor of education and
then many of these people have had
extremely bad educations and it's one
situation
in which they might
get a good education
but if
it depends what you mean by fundamental
reform as in do you think enough
opportunity is given to prisoners to
learn skills to improve themselves to
come out with a trade
uh well obviously you can i mean i would
be happy if it were increased
yeah i mean
and i think that is so irrespective i
mean supposing you you made all the
efforts in the world to improve it and
you you found
that actually it didn't
decrease the recidivism rate
i would still be in favor of it because
i think it's a kind of
ethical thing to do you you ought to
make an effort
even if it turns out that your effort
isn't entirely successful
but i also believe that prisoners were
[Music]
capable of a lot more than
than
um than our society demands of them not
only them but of huge numbers of people
in this
in this country
and you said you didn't believe in
rehabilitation quote unquote what do you
mean by that well i don't know what do
you mean by rehabilitation i mean i mean
i mean the first thing is the
rehabilitation means that there's
something wrong with them in the first
place
well you could argue there is isn't
there like going around like they make
bad decisions
is making bad decisions having something
wrong with you
um
i mean if you're going right i i've seen
some of the decisions you've made
no i'll push back on that i think if
you're going around you know uh
you know burgling 50 houses day in day
out i think there is something wrong
with you i think if you go around and
sexually assault someone i think there
is something wrong with you sexually
assaulting is one thing and
i agree for example i met
this is a small number of people
but you do meet people who from the very
earliest age
have done terrible things so you know
from the age of three they put the cat
in the washing machine and things like
that and whatever you know they do
they steal and lie
when there's absolutely no advantage to
it to them and they don't learn and then
they become aggressive and so on and so
forth and it's very difficult to believe
that there isn't something wrong with
them in the sense that
they've got a slightly different brain
from others and that's been recognized
for a long time you know used to be
called moral insanity
you know that they were saying from
every possible point of view but
they didn't have any moral sense and
they never learned any moral sins
so there are those people but the vast
majority i don't think have anything
anything wrong with them and as i said
they do actually stop spontaneously most
often not all but most
well let me give you a a phrasing of
rehabilitation that you can then destroy
with facts and logic so um to me
rehabilitation would be
to take someone who's in prison for
committing crime yes and they come out
and lead a quote unquote normal life
they have a job
they might have relationships family
whatever and they never well they
eventually do as i said they eventually
do that when their testosterone level
drops and and they're no longer trying
to make their mark on the world
i know i'm i'm of course but what i mean
if you have a long if you have a long
time in if someone has a long time in
prison
it's reasonable to give him assistance
to
uh
to reintegrate into a society which
amongst other things will have changed
since he last saw it
and you can't just chuck him out and say
well here's 50 quid now get on with it
um
which is
largely what happens
but
the same is true of drug addicts i mean
the reason rehabilitation for drug
addicts isn't a medical procedure in my
this is my view
it's that drug addicts have destroyed
their lives they've you know ruined
their relationship with their family
they know only drug addicts it's very
difficult for them to get a job because
if an employer says what have you been
doing for the last 10 years if they told
him the truth the drug the the employer
wouldn't want him so
that is kind of practical assistance
that
that people need so they might for
example need halfway houses
and that kind of thing to get back on
their feet
whether you call that rehabilitation i
don't know would you call that
rehabilitation part of the process i
would think yeah well in that case i
would be in favor of that yes
because
you can easily see that if you've
wasted or
ruined 10 years of your life you don't
just pick up the next day and
proceed as if nothing has happened in
the meantime
and where do you stand on
imprisoning drug addicts people who are
heroin addicts for instance causing
crime after crime after crime purely to
feed their addiction should we
criminalize these people or should we
treat it as hell well here you see i
disagree with your uh your
characterization of the problem
if you take drug addicts as i did in the
prison who ended up in prison drug
addicts what you found is that they they
had
most of them had been convicted often
many times before they ever took aaron
so insofar as there's a relationship
between taking heroin and crime it is
that the attraction to crime attracts
them to heroin and if you take heroin
addiction it's not something that just
happens to you
uh it doesn't it's not like parkinson's
disease and no one really knows where it
comes from and it's
just one of those terrible things
heron addiction is not like that heroin
addicts on the whole the injecting
heroin addicts
they go at it for about 18 months before
they ever start taking it regularly
they know all about it to become a
heroin addict you have to know where to
get your hearing you have to know how to
uh prepare it you have to know how to
inject it and where to get the syringes
from
most people find
injecting something that they wouldn't
really want to do unless they had to
so in other words it's not true
that
heroin hooks them they hook heroin
so it is a choice to be a heroin addict
and furthermore many many just give up
so
it is not true
that they
burgle houses just to feed their habit
and actually heroin addicts
and certainly more phoenix in the 1920s
were perfectly capable of going out to
work just like anybody else
oh really yeah
so this idea if anything they had a
better time yeah
so this idea of a junkie
committing crime in order to feed his
addiction is a very is shall we say it's
very oversimplified and i remember they
used to say one of them i remember i
should say not dave one said i went out
to work by which he meant he went out
burgling from nine to five i said
couldn't you do something other than
burgle
95 yeah
something a little less strenuous and
um
so i i i i don't think it's a simple
it's it's a simple matter it's a simple
and then but let's say they they are
addicted do we how should we treat that
is it as a criminal issue or is it as a
medicine if they do well i don't think i
would treat
i would say taking heroin is criminal
would treat it as criminal in itself but
if they commit crimes then i would say
yes yeah but i guess what francis is
getting at is is the what people call
the war on drugs the criminalization of
drug use well
i mean when people say
i mean i've had this discussion lots and
lots of times they say well we if
if we
um uh if we decriminalized if we made
everything available so you could just
go down the shop and buy your crack
uh then all the crime would disappear i
don't believe that no
and i don't believe that needles are
going to be beaten into plowshares once
we've uh decriminalized
uh
things i i think that we will find
something else and people always say
well look at colombia for example
violent and so well people forget that
colombia was extremely violent but
in fact more violent before
the existence of cake or the widespread
use of cocaine
as was mexico
so
the idea that if we could uh if we
uh decriminalized everything i don't
think is there anybody who suggests we
should decriminalize everything no but
what about something like cannabis
that's where the battle well that
that is more discussable however of
course it doesn't necessarily mean
there'll be less interference from the
state it might eventually be more
because people will have to start being
tested for cannabis all the time and so
on and so forth i mean there are many
situations in which people cannot even
if they're legal even if it's legalized
should not take cannabis for example
driving or you don't want your train
driver to be
high on cannabis or your it would take
the service will take a lot longer yeah
it would but but we don't test people
for alcohol in that way do we so yeah
well we do in a way i mean in the sense
that we
i mean most of the time we're not
allowed to be drunk actually that's
another thing we don't if we don't
enforce the laws against alcohol
uh being drunk and incapable or drunk
and disorderly we don't do anything like
that and that's why
all foreigners who come to this country
are absolutely appalled i am one such
and i was about to make the joke that it
seems to me just british english culture
more than anything to be drunk and
disorderly on a friday well it did yes
well it's not it's not legal
and
uh but nobody enforces the law
and it it wasn't
people would say oh what about gin lane
they always say that once you start as
if nothing happened between gin lane and
1980
and
so anyway um
isn't i mean of course it has become
culture but if it's become culture it's
a very bad culture i mean the fact that
something is a culture doesn't mean that
it's good
well coming from a russian i think
criticizing british drinking culture
would be wrong so let me instead because
i must have seen that very unpleasant
things yeah i'm not sure i could i could
really pull that off but let me
final question before we get to our
final final question penultimate
question therefore what did you learn
from working in prison all this time
i would say that
everyone is equal
that's what i learned
for example to give you an example and
no i'm not allowed are you allowed to
swear on this oh
absolutely absolutely
okay well prisoners would come in so i
got this [ __ ] headache so i'd say
well before we go any further what's
different from the headache and the
[ __ ] headache
and actually there is a headache that
you can get on sexual intercourse but
that's not what they meant
[Laughter]
my girlfriend suffers from it regularly
thank you um anyhow
so they'd say well that's how i speak
and i say yes that's what i'm
complaining of
[Music]
that has got to be one of the most
surreal conversations in the history of
humanity
i can just see you there in your tweed
jacket go
carry on
so
uh
i mean
when i said that they could stop no one
had ever asked them to stop
but they could stop they discovered it
is possible to speak for longer than
about three seconds without using that
word
anyway some would say well
why shouldn't i you know that's the way
i speak and i said well supposing i said
to you at the end of this consultation i
hear some [ __ ] tablets
take
two of the [ __ ] every four [ __ ]
hours and if they don't [ __ ] work
come the [ __ ] back and i'll give you
some [ __ ]
you'd be a bit surprised
i would say so
i established that i knew how to use the
word
so it's so i'd say we're equal i don't
talk to you like that you don't talk to
me like that
so that's what i learned i think
what i'm hearing underpinning all of
that anthony is that
we pretend way too much
about other people's capacity to
whatever it is to behave to we pretend
that things some people just can't do
this or we can't not do that or or it's
the way that we you know it's the it's
the child and yes the childhood is
important and yes education is important
but what i'm hearing underpinning all of
that is
actually if we call ourselves out and
each other out on bad behavior sometimes
it's just because bad behavior is easier
or we're used to it or whatever it is
yeah is that what i'm hearing is that
yes i would say that's roughly right and
i believe that that was your experience
as a teacher
that is very much so that we
part of the reason the school system is
no longer fit for purpose
is because of bad behavior
you cannot be taught you cannot learn in
a classroom if there is a disruption
every four to five minutes no learning
happens and we don't want to talk about
it because unfortunately in the
education system things have gone so far
to the left that it's almost seen as an
act of oppression first for a teacher to
say stop doing that yeah and to have
rules in the classroom one of my
colleagues uh and one of the best
teachers i ever saw was described as
right wing because uh she was a strict
teacher this is a woman who dedicated
her life to teaching in a poor deprived
primary school in east london yeah
yeah and actually i i think i mean you
would know better than i
uh that children are happier with that
oh absolutely because you know what it
makes them feel safe because when there
is strict st orders in place when there
is rules it gives them a structure and
particularly for the poorest and most
vulnerable kids that's what they crave
because they don't have it at home
there we go there we go it seems to me
common sense really it does but we seem
to and maybe this
ties into everything that we've talked
we're talking about we are living in a
society which is rapidly abandoning
common sense yeah
good ending mate look we had a lovely
funny story and then let's just wrap it
up on the fact that the world's going
down the toilet that's how i end all my
gigs brilliant yeah it explains the
reaction now
anthony theodor dalrymple thank you so
much for coming on we've got one final
question for you as always which is what
is the one thing that we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be
uh
well i think we're talking about the
death of common sense and the
centralization of the marginal
so that what you get is a marginal
phenomenon taking over our um
taking over our imagination completely
so that
for example a good example is
transexualism what comes next is the
interesting question
oh hello hello and what do you think
what do you think is coming next i think
it'll be incest
explain
i think incest will be permissible
soon because there's no logical argument
against it
i mean
biology
but there were you don't have to have
children right you don't have to have
children
so two consenting adults exactly go for
it
there will be celebrations up and down
cornwall
mate you did that joke last time we got
a lot of angry letters no i did it
against wales no you did cornell the one
before that you're losing track of your
own [ __ ] jokes jesus christ
well thank you for that i really
appreciate it we've got a couple of
questions for locals i'm sure they're
going to be even more problematic than
that uh but in the meantime uh where can
people find your work online where uh
well uh which books should they buy of
yours particularly given something so i
would say all of them
you would say that
well of course amazon you can find
i mean it's not that i'm keen on amazon
but
but you it's very convenient and um
you know various journals i don't write
much in this country
anymore i can see why
make sure to check anthony's work under
his pseudonym theodore dalrymple uh i'm
sure you will agree with me it's been an
absolutely incredible interview and
we've got a couple of questions for
locals we're going to ask in a second
but in the meantime thank you so much
for watching and listening we'll see you
very soon another brilliant episode like
this one or raw show they always go out
7 p.m uk time 2 p.m eastern standard and
the interviews are also available as a
podcast if you like your trigonometry on
the go take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our local community using the
link below